you're part of one of the greatest Duos
of all time who's who's the Mount
Rushmore of rap Duos for you give me the
top four rap Duos of all time Run DMC
yep um Outcast
yeah you you can't say yourself right
um that you can't let me see um wow the
the Duos I'm stuck right now give me the
top four man Mount
Rushmore so far you're two for two
though yeah yeah yeah but but but why
why am I going
blank there's so many there's there's
there's mob deep
there's right okay you got it okay well
I'mma
go and then that's the other thing do we
consider the producer
rapper people the mob deep the Gangstar
the definitely and then you
have see I don't look at the the the
down dud because Eric be Rock Kim
because they put both names but but
that's my favorite raap in the world but
again you you have
um mop which is underrated group in the
world Billy I like that's when it comes
to
underrated lyrically I mean this
fantastic [__] M was one of my
favorite ra groups of all time I saw
them perform live and they used to roll
with that chick Fox the girl who's on
four alarm Blaze and uh the sound guy
kept he was [__] with their sound at
the show and I'm like in the front row
and fox beats the [__] out of the sound
guy sound turns off sound turns off
there's no more the concert's over they
haven't even done Annie up yet these
[__] got into the crowd and did Annie
up Acappella with the crowd it was sick
w wow is is is Snoop and Dre a do is no
I think they got to be I mean they are
but I think they got to be like it'd be
like saying rayquan a ghost it's like
well like they were I know you're right
you're right you're right you but I
think Outcast I think EPMD when I think
Duos I think I think Gangstar I think
uh but not but again you you you like
you said for when you think about the
pepper so and pepper you think about
again but RMC of course erican Parish
but I'm saying is Run DMC a Duo there's
three of them right but Run DMC is Run
DMC even though they say d j Master J
two rap but I'm saying but that's why I
said do we qualify Gangstar because
Primo is just the producer right do we
qualify Eric B and rock him because Eric
B was making beats he Rock move that's
what I'm saying so it's like it is if
we're if we're saying just the two are
like you have to also rap then it's you
guys it's Outcast it's probably mob deep
but you got to think about the the
impact of a ball the theall and MJ UG
and UGK I would put UGK as my fourth
spot right UGK for sure hum cuz if you
think of UGK and like how they
influenced every I know I got UGK in the
record
wow you got pimpy
vers come on man Kevin I think you don't
know me man like that man I don't pimpy
I know I know we always like like
there's you know the most influential
list and I think you know it's Jay it's
Pac it's you go rock him but pimpy's in
that discussion it's crazy how much
pimps he
oh even though it was only one album
though but I'm looking at Clips still
too man Clips no no no they had three
albums they had three yeah but but but
I'm saying with the the impact of their
first two albums obviously Lord willing
now you know what if we're talking about
my personal favorite that's a different
list cuz to me the clips as you
dangerous they're highly regarded in my
life danger Dangerous yeah you're right
for sure man I got you so uh first week
of April the dynamic Duos is coming yeah
and and again at the end of the day like
it's it's a it's a
uh a situation oh too I got to help the
scar too oh hey man rest in peace to Sea
price man
again I don't know if if I'm dropping
everything at once because there's so
many and I want to be able to to to to
keep the excitement but I can go on and
tell you that nobody said no to me
people loved the idea love the concept
and everybody was like yo I got you I
got got you I got you I got you you know
is it like um working with because
you've already oh Styles P and J oh I
mean shout out to them but I was going
to say the fact they've never did that
album together just the two you know
they need to do just the the they need
to do their version of Iron Man or you
know only buil for Cuban leaks right um
well well they did
two two purple tapes no I'm talking
about ghost F or I'm talking about Jay
and styles oh there I I want them to
just do their version of that but I
don't know but they don't want to leave
out she I get um with that being said
though uh is it is it like because you
you have a lot of people on that on this
project or on these projects that aren't
with us anymore yes uh Prodigy uh Sea
price Tupac but I was going to ask you
like is it is how is it like how much is
it like when you hear Sean Price's vote
for the first time like I feel like I
would get goosebumps and just be like
damn
like the is the pressure higher knowing
you got to have to kind of like deliver
because n because again it doesn't you
know it's like you you dope at what you
do yeah I ain't whack right no for sure
so so so so when when that beat come on
it's going to be like
oh why that back right you know because
I'm I don't have it it sounds death posy
that come from his brother Leo Cohen you
know like if sounds death posy mean
somebody say yo how you like that oh
that's dope yeah I don't have the people
that's agreeing you know don't don't
agree with me you don't [__] with it
don't [__] with it just tell me the
truth right right right you know what
I'm saying so that's why I I like about
people who I'm around you know and I
know if it's not good cuz I sit there
and sit there myself and be like oh nah
this I could have add some better drums
you know what I'm saying what